To give you an overview of the OpenColor I.O., color management, Unreal Engine offers built-in
support for OpenColor I.O. to convert colors of linear media in several ways.
So when you use media source like captured clips or live feeds in your project, you can
apply the color conversion to make sure those media sources match your computer generated
elements in Unreal Engine.
So while you're working, you can apply the color conversions to your viewport, and this
will be helpful so that the reference frames you see as you are working in the editor will
be consistent with your chosen color space.
You can then reapply another color conversion to the composited feed, your output from Composure,
and this really helps with CG elements and live frames to help them blend more convincingly
whilst preserving the colors of the original shots faithfully.
So you can export using the movie render queue, which we'll go over in a few slides here,
and you can choose to apply a color space transformation to your output video.
And then a new asset is the OpenColor Configuration asset, which you'll use to manage the color
profiles that you want to work with.
So from your plugins, you just want to make sure you go to the edit window, go down to
plugins and check for OpenColor I.O. and make sure it's enabled.
If it wasn't enabled, you'll just have to restart your editor and then you should be
good to go with OpenColor I.O.